who is since you're one of the biggest
podcasters in the RPM space
um red pill is just basically seeing the
world as how it is and it's it's
basically like the way they describe it
is blue pill is like the lies you've
been told by society and like feminism
and you take the red pill and you see
the world for how it is okay
okay okay
interesting so it's not the Matrix yeah
there's probably a more official
definition out there that's just how I
would describe it no no it's a good
definition I get it so what would you
say was your red pill moment what was
the thing that broke the camels back was
Arcane yeah I'm red pool you know it's
interesting um I I just was doing
reaction videos I started with rap
reaction videos
and then somebody just sent me Kevin
Samuels
and I started like reacting to stuff I
called into a show
um I'm I called and do there's some
other show I called in too too I forgot
what it was but yeah I just started
reacting to all the content and there's
just a lot of stories where I was like
oh my God like I've seen that
um I didn't know if there was like a
necessarily like a red pill moment it
was just more
um the content was interesting I just
kept watching
you know what I always say that my first
introduction to the red pool was also
Kevin Samuels
um so about two years ago I was studying
four exams at University and
I think one this guy called the black
Hokage on YouTube just started speaking
about him I was like who is this guy he
keeps mentioning Kevin Samuel's like who
is this so then I started watching him
at that point I think he still had but
look under just above 100 000
subscribers at that point so it's still
relatively unknown in comparison to what
he became
and I just like realized a lot of stuff
he said was actually very true and
helpful right exactly exactly especially
the stuff he said to men like you know
basically stop being a bum and yeah
start living your life the way you want
it to be rather than just expecting
things to come your way especially for
the black community I think that's a
very important message but it was
something that I found to be
interesting at the very least however
okay
I wouldn't call myself red people okay I
wouldn't call myself Red Bull because
I would say that a lot of stuff the Red
Bulls says the Red Bull movement says is
relatively Common Sense yeah I would
agree and Common Sense isn't so common
nowadays very true very true depending
on the culture you're from I think
that's very true but a lot of stuff they
say actually is synonymous with things
that you're taught in African homes and
I've said to you before I'm not red but
I'm just Nigerian you know so it's like
a lot of stuff that like stuff like okay
I wouldn't personally want my wife to
earn more than me because it just
doesn't make sense when it comes to
um you know having children and the
person having to take time off you know
it doesn't make sense for the family
people would say that's a misogynistic
or whatever I think it's just practical
it doesn't make sense to to be the uh
the lower earner in that sense I
wouldn't make a quick but I'll work
harder in order to earn more than that
but then
I just I can't call myself red pool
because I think
a lot of the times when it comes to Red
pool content we fall into the same trap
that we see many of the radical
feminists fall into and so when we did
that a street interview and the goal was
saying oh all men are this all men are
that all men do this right
overseas it's not true overseas just not
something that makes sense right but
then
we will see a lot of red pill content
say basically
do the exact same thing but with women
saying all women are like this all women
do this all women do that I've never
heard them say all I've heard them say
modern women do this which is a very big
distinction so what would you say to the
distinction between modern women and
women in general
um I would say modern women are women
that are chasing their careers over a
family
and
um have bought into some of the lies of
feminism that's what I would call a
modern woman but wouldn't you say that
even women who don't necessarily follow
careers so you know the ones who are
just Instagram baddies quote unquote
they're not exactly foreign
you could say they're following a career
they're just not that good at it which
is bums yeah but they're trying to
they're trying to like they're following
an Instagram career it's just not a
successful one
I mean I think most women are modern
today but like the point is women are
different today than they were in the
1950s it's a different breed of woman I
don't think you're wrong but then you
think that the guys are also very
different yeah I agree most most red
pills channels would tell you that too
yeah like even even
um even fresh and fit they'll say men
are more feminine now than ever they are
yeah yeah I will say that but to me it
like starts with the women
I would say because as someone who
watches a lot of television and Cinema
and you know I'd like to study it just
just for you know to improve my content
sometimes I will say that the media is
pushing a certain image and narrative
towards men and I think that you know
when we see an advert or on a TV show
there's always a bumbling idiot dads and
dogs yes extremely competent woman who
has to come in and save him from his
stupidity and I do think that's a very
bad message to be telling men because
you know they're gonna they're meant to
grow up and help to propagate Society
but then if you're making them weak
[__] yeah what sort of society are we
going to live in unfortunately yeah the
bunch of men that are afraid of a [__]
why I don't get afraid about a [__] you
guys are like I need to call my wife to
do something I'm like you have to ask
your wife
what do you mean I I get that and it's I
think it's that's why I would say that
the red pool move into something that's
extremely necessary for Society at the
moment yeah especially because you know
when we have such extreme content
um you know on gear towards the other
side that's in very far leftist feminist
you need something to counteract that
even even when it's that feminist it's
ingrained and just like modern day like
talking happy wife happy life that's
yeah that's a phrase but what about his
happiness no one cares I think that's a
good segue into dating and you know in
sexual Dynamics what would you say is
your opinion in current dating in based
not your personal experience but based
on what you know and what you've heard
um I would just say modern women are
side chicks
in most sense like there's a small
percentage of guys [__] all the girls
I mean sorry having sex
[Laughter]
um and yeah and it's like one out of
three men under 30 are virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year and so
80 of women are sexually active so who
are they having sex with it's a small
percentage of the man they only swipe
right in dating apps like five percent
of the time it's all the same guys so
uh yeah modern women are side chicks and
they're not getting into and like that's
why you see all these tick tocks of
girls hitting like 30 and they're saying
oh I've never been in a real
relationship well why because you're a
side chick
that makes sense yeah that makes sense I
mean like how many girls has like Drake
slept I mean that's the extreme but you
know when you see the extreme you see
what's happening throughout Society
right it how many girls does Drake slept
with yeah future
I think my my issue with
when we say stuff like uh modern women
or side chicks and things like that my
only issue with a statement like that is
the fact that
it doesn't account for the fact that
most women actually
um even in you this is the stuff from
the CDC in the US I think the average
body count of woman in the US is full so
um it's actually not for us around like
seven to eight that's the last time
that's last one I've seen yeah but um
that that accounts all women from like
young age groups to Old creators yeah so
if you if you break it down where it's
um
like with just the younger age group
it's like 12.
and that's that's average which means
half of people are at more than that and
I and as you know women lie about their
body counts of course of course well I
think and even just anecdotally like
when I ask I ask girls